it's really difficult to know what's
right on kovid given all the uncertainty
all the chaos especially when you step
outside the pure biology virology of it
and you start to get into policy yes
it's really yeah it's just trade-offs
yeah like transmissibility of the virus
sure just knowing
if 65 of the population gets vaccinated
what effect would that have
just even knowing those things just
modeling all those things
um
given all the other incentives I mean
Pfizer
but yeah you had the CEO of fires around
your podcast did you leave that
conversation feeling like
this is a person who is consciously
uh
reaping windfall profits on a dangerous
uh vaccine and putting everyone at
intolerable risk or do you think this
person did you think this person was
making a good faith attempt to save
lives and had no
no bad no no taint of bad incentives
or something uh the thing I sensed and I
I felt in part
it was a failure on my part
but I I sense that I was talking to a
politician
so it's not thinking of those
malevolence there or benevolence
there was uh he just had a job he put on
a suit and I was talking to a suit not a
human being
now he said that his son was a big fan
of the podcast which is why he wanted to
do it so I thought I would be talking to
a human being and
I asked challenging questions but I
thought the internet thinks otherwise
every single question
in that interview
was a challenging one
but it wasn't grilling which is what
people seem to want to do with
pharmaceutical companies there's a deep
distrust of pharmaceutical companies but
what was the alternative I mean I I
totally get right that's windfall
profits at a time of of you know Public
Health Emergency looks bad is it bad it
is a bad look right but yeah what do how
do we
reward
and return Capital to to Risk Takers who
are who will spend a billion dollars to
design a new drug for a disease that may
maybe only harms of you know a single
digit percentage of the populations like
well what do we want to encourage and
who do we want to get rich I mean so
like the person who cures cancer
do we want that person to get rich or
not we want the we want the person who
uh
gave us the iPhone to get rich but we
don't want the person who who cures
cancer to get rich what what are we
trying I think it's a very gray area so
what we want is the person who declares
that they have a cure for cancer to have
authenticity and transparency this like
I think we're good now as a population
smelling
and there is something about the the
Pfizer CEO for example just CEO is a
pharmaceutical companies in general just
because they're so lawyered up so much
marketing PR people that they are you
just smell you're not talking
to real human that it they just it just
feels like none of it is transparent to
us as a public so like this whole
uh talking point that Pfizer is only
interested in helping people just
doesn't ring true even though it very
well could be true it's the same thing
with Bill Gates who seems to be at scale
helping a huge amount of people in the
world and yet there's something about
the way he delivers that message or
people like
they seem suspicious
what's happening underneath this right
there's certain kinds of communication
styles that seem to uh be more
uh service better Catalyst for
conspiracy theories
and I'm not sure what what that is
because I don't think there's an
alternative
for capitalism
in delivering drugs that help people
but also at the same time that it seems
to need to be a more transparency and
plus like regulation that actually makes
sense versus it seems like
uh pharmaceutical companies are
susceptible to corruption
yeah I I worry about all that but I I
also do think that most of the people go
into those fields and most of the people
going into government they want to do
good doing it for good and they're
non-psychopaths trying to get good
things done and trying trying to solve
hard problems and they they're not
trying to get rich I mean many of the
people are it's like
they're
but I mean bad incentives or or
something again if if you order that
phrase 30 times uh on this podcast but
it's it's just almost everywhere it
explains normal people creating terrible
harm right it's not that there are that
many bad people you know and
uh yes it makes it makes the truly bad
people that much more remarkable and
worth paying attention to but
the bad incentives and the bad and the
and the
the uh the power of bad ideas
to do much more harm because I mean
that's what that what that's what gets
good people running in the wrong
direction or or um
doing things that are that are clearly
creating unnecessary suffering